regarde casimir j'ai réussi à mettre à
nu plus je n'ai rien du tout moi pour
aller plus vite je les place deux par
deux
un bravo d'eysines et c'est raté je
voulu aller trop vite mieux pas du tout
j'ai fait exprès c'était pour vous
montrer ce qu'il ne faut pas faire
c'est avant tout une question de
patience mais surtout pas de gestes
brusques alors je prends un cube je le
pose bien au dessus et il se place tout
doucement sur celui d'en dessous voilà
pour sûr c'est un jeu d'enfant n'a jeu
d'enfant chacun ça ne veut pas dire que
ce soit un jeu facile à réaliser au
après les avoir placé deux pare d'un
jean les places 3 à 3 et je rêve gagner
le concours un
éditeur vous en tant qu est-ce qui se
meuvent dans le silence recueilli la
précision silencieuse l'attention
matinale connaissent les hauts faits
sportifs les plus éclatants chez mamie
bravo monsieur du snarr vous venez de
décrire exactement ce que je suis en
train de créer un an dernier cubain et
je gagne de façon écrasante
wimille et mise
enceinte attend d appuyer sur le sens
donnez-vous bon si on
ne fera pas la peine mademoiselle julie
au jour une canne me suffira mais ce
n'est quand même pas de ma faute si on
m'a donné des cubes qui ne sont pas
place si vous voulez vous prouver une
canne un mythe monsieur lice n'ont pas
la sienne oui ça sera avec plaisir que
je l'a prêté récemment gelé pas porter
aujourd'hui quasiment ça messieurs
thibault il me semblait que vous l'aviez
en arrivant mais oui julia raison vous
avez tout à laisser traîner quelque part
le suisse nomes cherchons la
loi c'est votre
jeu les fans
quel dommage que casimir est interrompu
le concours où vous avez réalisé là un
équilibre extraordinaire je dois le
reconnaître assez bien bras un ballon
mais canal vient au
je me demande comment cette pile de pub
pour tenir tout ça l'installeur
casimir désigné je crois que j'ai
compris en garde
au si les semaines regarde
et voilà la can de monsieur du snav
est un prêcheur armée n'est pas du tout
cas s'ils ne se l'est posée là par
hasard je t'assure et périls mes pensées
d'équilibrage et natural jeu il ne croit
pas et ils ont raison c'est un tricheur
et alors juste au moment où j'avais
gagné le concours mais cube
le pied du facteur j'ai toujours dit que
les jeux et les concours de jeux de
construction était un sport dangereux
seule la ville de monsieur lui ce noble
donnait de vous l'avait coincé cuba avec
sa cale
avec cinq ânes mais mais c'est ce que le
casimir je n'aurais jamais pensé que
monsieur du stand pointe aussi tricheurs
dire que moi même je n'aurais pas eu
cette idée là
c'est bien ça nous avons décidé d'en ont
commencé le concours
hippique et compte casimir voilà ce que
je te prends pour moi je vis venir voit
aussi à ce concours mais je vais me
cacher et je suis vendrell tous les
gestes de monsieur du snob et s'ils
essayent de tricher je coach avoir est
comme ça quoi
qu'en cas d'accord bravo léonard or on
va bien rigoler nouvelle conduite à un
accord ouah
ouah ouah
mes très chers amis je vous remercie du
fond du coeur malgré mon forfait de tout
à l'heure vous avez accepté
magnanimement de mettre à nouveau à
vendre concours et ainsi me permettre de
gagner une nouvelle fois mais vous
n'aviez pas gagné t'es sûr que c'est
mieux ça me souviens plus détails mais
il me semble que j'ai assez parlé tous
les deux le concours est ouvert à tous
mais il manque encore le facteur donc la
tendance coach n'est pas venu bon
commençons sans lui il a sans doute eu
peur de recevoir quelques chances sur le
pied
vous avez entendu monsieur du sna bon
quoi
mais les jappements du chien
pourquoi me regarde au dessus comme ça
gagnent et non ses moi
oh mais c'était vos facteurs
bonjour mes amis
vous j'en ai entendu comme je fais le
chien
j'ai beaucoup trop d'enjeux s'ouvrir si
je suis désignée je n'ai pas triché j'ai
remarqué oui c'est une erreur mais a mis
un à un grâce à sa cause d'un ce
malheureux incident nous allons devoir
une fois plus remporté ce concours un
mois on recommence on décore monsieur du
snop sera guérie c'est un malheureux
concours de circonstances ah non
monsieur du snav c'est un malheureux
concours de construction
pourrait bien ne manque plus que casimir
bon maintenant éloignons nous
suffisamment les uns des autres pour
éviter les accidents vous avez un réseau
françois soyons prudents euros et air un
peu plus loin
au voile à casimir
ça marche
casimir que tard estime qu'on a ne
t'inquiète pas je lis je n'ai rien mais
j'ai remarqué quand on se mettait
généralement des pansements après s'être
blessé moi j'ai préféré les mettre avant
comme ça je ne crains plus rien